-Special Counsel Robert Mueller
has filed the first charges
in his investigation
of the Trump campaign's
potential ties to Russia,
and, of course, news
that the charges were coming
sent President Trump
and his allies
into an unhinged frenzy
over the weekend.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Trump White House knew today
was going to be a bad news day,
so you'd think they would savor
any chance to take a break
from the chaos
and project normalcy.
For example, on Friday,
Trump engaged in the
presidential Halloween tradition
of handing out candy
to the children of members
of the White House press corps.
And yet Trump could not resist
turning the innocent task
of handing out candy
into an opportunity
to air his grievances
about the media.
-I cannot believe the media
produced
such beautiful children.
How the media did this,
I don't know.
Do you know who they are?
Huh?
They're the friendly media.
They're the frie--
That's the press.
Oh, you're gonna grow up
to be like your parents?
Mm.
[ Laughter ]
Don't answer.
That can only get me in trouble,
that question.
So how does the press treat you?
[ Laughter ]
I'll bet you get treated
better by the press
than anybody in the world,
right?
Well, congratulations, folks.
You did a good job.
Here you did a good job.
I wouldn't say
you did very well here.
-That's because
you're the president,
not one of their children.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You never hug me.
You make me go to bed early.
And when I want ice cream
for breakfast, you say no."
[ Laughter ]
Also, look at the faces
of those kids.
[ Laughter ]
They're all looking at Trump
and thinking,
"You're the reason
my daddy drinks."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But it actually --
It actually got worse than that,
because as he was
handing out the candy,
Trump made this comment
to some of the children.
-Who likes this?
You have no weight problems.
That's the good news, right?
-"You have no weight problem."
I can't wait to see how Trump
botches the presidential
turkey pardon.
"You're gonna live, but
the rest of your family, dead.
They're all dead.
And you only have one more year.
You're probably not getting
a second pardon."
[ Laughter ]
"So it's stuffing for you,
friend, but congratulations
on what I hope
will be a good year.
Did we get the pictures?
Can I go now?"
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump's weekend
got off to a rough start,
and then, this morning,
he woke up to even worse news.
-Former Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort
and his business associate
Rick Gates have been indicted
by a federal grand jury
on a number of felony charges,
including money laundering
and conspiracy
against the United States.
-Now, I'm no legal expert,
but conspiracy
against the United States
does not sound good.
Doesn't leave much room
for a plea bargain.
"What if I just cop
to conspiracy against Delaware?
You know Delaware
was asking for it!"
[ Laughter ]
Things really could not be worse
for Paul Manafort right now.
Although, on the bright side...
-You have no weight problems.
That's the good news, right?
-Okay.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Bright side.
Now, the indictment
against Manafort
alleges that he laundered
millions of dollars
and failed to register as an
agent of a foreign government.
The indictment has all kinds
of details about how Manafort
allegedly laundered money
by purchasing items
from high-end stores,
including a home-entertainment
company, a men's clothing store,
a landscaper in the Hamptons,
and an antique rug store.
Wow. He allegedly laundered
$1 million through a rug store,
and not only that,
the rug he bought
wasn't even convincing.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And Trump, of course,
could not help but respond
to the news today on Twitter
in a way that made very clear
he is not handling this well.
First, he tweeted...
But then, three minutes later,
he added...
[ Laughter ]
He is so bad at this.
It's like getting pulled over
and saying,
"I wasn't speeding, officer.
And also, there's no cocaine
in the glove compartment!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Don't look there!
It's a waste of your time!"
But maybe there's
a perfectly good explanation
for all 12 counts
against Manafort.
I mean, does he sound
like a guilty man to you?
-So, to be clear, Mr. Trump
as no financial relationships
with any Russian oligarchs.
-If that's what he said,
I -- That's what I --
That's obviously
what the -- our position is.
[ Laughter ]
-"Uh, uh...
Uh, um...uh, you know,
I'm gonna...
Uh, you know,
I think I'll probably --
I think I'll probably
die in jail."
[ Laughter ]
But that Manafort news
isn't the only bombshell today,
because it was also revealed
that Mueller's team
arrested a third
Trump campaign official,
a foreign policy adviser
named George Papadopoulos,
who, unlike Manafort,
has already pled guilty
to lying to the FBI.
Papadopoulos allegedly met with
a professor tied to the Kremlin
who promised dirt
on Hillary Clinton.
According to the indictment...
Wow. So it was the professor
in the dining room
with the e-mails.
[ Laughter ]
The Trump administration
is turning into a game of Clue,
but since it's Trump,
Clueless.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Apparently...
Apparently,
Papadopoulos tried to lie
about this interaction
to the FBI.
Papadopoulos said, falsely,
"he learned that information
prior to joining the campaign,"
but, in fact,
"The professor
only took interest
in Papadopoulos
because of his status
with the campaign."
Of course he did.
You think he was interested in
you because of your personality?
Or maybe it's just fun saying
your name in a Russian accent.
"Meester Papadabbaluh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Please, let's have breakfast,
Meester Papadabbaluh."
[ Laughter ]
"You can have
the Papawaffaluhs."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, now that Manafort
has been charged,
Trump and his team are trying
to distance themselves from him.
But during the campaign,
Trump and his aides
went out of their way repeatedly
to emphasize how important
Manafort was
to their operations.
-Who do you believe
will take over the campaign?
Will it be Paul Manafort?
-Yeah, I think Paul
is totally in charge.
-Nobody should underestimate
how much Paul Manafort did
to really help get this campaign
to where it is right now.
-Paul Manafort
has done an amazing job.
He's here someplace.
Where's Paul?
Paul Manafort.
Oh, good.
You made it.
-"Oh, good.
Where were you?"
"I don't -- I was, um..."
[ Laughter ]
"I was, uh...
I was doin' some Russia stuff."
[ Laughter ]
When none of your defenses work,
there's always the option
of ignoring the news completely.
As other news outlets
were going wall-to-wall
with coverage
of the Manafort indictment,
here's what Fox News
thought was more important.
-All right, this cheeseburger
emoji causing a frenzy online.
We've been talking about it
all morning.
Can you see
what's wrong with this picture?
The cheese is underneath
the hamburger.
Who does that?
-Unless the answer
is Paul Manafort, who cares?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
You know...
Fox News, if you really
want to talk about emojis,
you could at least
focus on the ones
that are relevant
to the Trump White House.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Fox News
was just following the playbook
they and the Trump team
have adhered to all weekend
after the news
that pending criminal charges
came down on Friday.
Trump went on a Twitter rant
in which he tried
to distract from the news
and lashed out at everyone
from James Comey to the
Democrats to Hillary Clinton.
-President Trump released a
torrent of tweets this weekend,
his frustration building
to an all-caps crescendo --
"Never seen
such Republican anger and unity
as I have concerning
the lack of investigation
on Clinton-made fake dossier.
The uranium to Russia deal,
the 33,000-plus deleted e-mails
that Comey fix
and so much more.
Instead, they look
at phony Trump/Russia collusion
which doesn't exist.
The Dems are using this terrible
and bad for our country
witch hunt for evil politics,
but the Republicans
are now fighting back
like never before.
There is so much guilt
by Democrats, Clinton,
and now the facts
are pouring out.
Do something!"
-"Do something"?
He sounds like a supervillain
barking orders at his henchmen
after James Bond escapes.
"He's getting away!
Do something!"
But his henchmen
are yelling back, "We can't!
We're all under
federal Investigation!"
[ Laughter ]
But The most disturbing thing --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The most disturbing thing
about the right-wing reaction
to the Mueller news this weekend
was their frothing obsession
with Hillary Clinton.
The writers manufactured a
series of fake Clinton scandals
to try to muddy the waters
and distract
from the very real
Russia investigation.
For example, they've dredged up
an old uranium deal from 2010
that was approved
by nine different agencies
and had nothing to do
with Hillary Clinton.
To try to claim she was the one
who colluded with Russia.
And Trump himself
immediately picked up
on that absurd talking point.
-Well, I think
the uranium sale to Russia
and the way it was done,
so underhanded with tremendous
amounts of money being passed,
I actually think
that's Watergate modern-age.
-You know what?
From now on, I think you should
only get
to talk about uranium deals
if you can actually explain
what uranium is.
Mr. President?
-You know what uranium is,
right?
This thing called nuclear
weapons and other things.
Like, lots of things
are done with uranium,
including some bad things.
[ Laughter ]
-Trump always sounds
like a high schooler
who forgot to study
for the quiz.
"Oxygen --
I don't have to tell you,
oxygen does good things,
and then you have uranium,
bad things.
And tungsten -- Oh, don't get me
started on tungsten.
It's where
the tongue comes from."
We're entering
a new and intense phase
of the Mueller investigation,
and Trump and his allies
are doing everything they can
to stop or discredit it.
On the one hand,
Trump claims his team
is doing
some really good things,
but in reality,
it looks like they were up to...
-Some bad things.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]